- We'll take a bunch of suggestions.
I'll come to smart side of the room first,
just cause you guys,
what would you like to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Underpants.
- Underpants.
Do you have a, do you want to be,
you really let yourself
down smart side of the room.
(adience laughing)
I was like we'll probably get
some type of quantum mechanics
stuff from over here.
No underpants.
Let's get a specific type of underpants.
- Hanes.
- Tighty Whities.
- One sec, you said Hanes,
the specific brand and you
said Tighty Whities cool.
Do Hanes make tighty whities?
- Yes.
- Wow, a lot of women knew that just,
and it's the only thing
my mom will wear that's,
I have to say tightie whities,
when you have a good body
tightie whities do look good.
Unfortunately the only person
I've seen wear tighty whities
is my dad.
(audience laughing)
- And they do not look good.
Cause I think they are
like XXL that he wears,
they are not supposed
to be tighty whities,
they just (mumbles)
Hanes Tighty Whities underpants.
You guys, let's raise
the bar a little bit.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Nicola Tesla.
- Nicolai Tesla, amazing,
that's pretty cool
Thank you for that Nikolai Tesla.
I'm saying Nikolai, is
it Nicolai or Nicola?
You just answered with the sound,
I was like, oh, he's hesitating just,
let me think about that,
But you were so confident
not ah, it's it's ah.
whereas if he'd said ai I'd be like,
oh, a Scottish person agreeing.
So Hanes Tighty Whities, Nikola Tesla.
I'm sorry, I thought it was Nikolai
cause Nicola is a girl's name.
But that's okay.
Those crazy Russians, was he Russian?
(indistinct)
Serbian, wow Nicola Tesla fans.
He's Serbian, are you guys Serbian?
You look like you could be Serbian.
I feel like you've done some war crimes.
You look,
(laughing)
Your sister-in-law?
Wow, is she here?
- She's done some war crimes.
Wow, gosh, I'm gonna
move on quickly cause,
little (mumbles) down
here is chucked in away.
Okay back of the room.
Let's move on from war criminals and
let's get a suggestion from you guys.
- Monkey torture.
- 7-Eleven.
- One second, what did you say?
- Monkey Torture.
- Monkey torture?
Okay, okay, Hanes Tighty
Whities, Nikola Tesla,
monkey torture.
I'm sorry 7-Eleven (mumbles).
I mean I know will take
7-Eleven as well, that's fine.
We don't have that in my
country it's pretty cool.
In my country, that's just,
you know, the 7th of November,
which, cause we do the days
the right way around guys.
day, month, year that makes sense.
You guys are like, oh month, day, year,
which makes no sense you're the worst.
Not as bad as China, China's the worst,
they do year, month, day,
which makes no sense.
Like why is the year the
first thing you wanna know?
Excuse me, you got the date.
Yeah It's Dog.
(laughing)
- Why do I need to know that?
So 7-Eleven, Monkey Torture,
Hanes Tighty Whities,
Nikola Tesla.
Middle front of the room, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Woman] North Dakota
(laughing)
- Oh wow, never has that been
said with such enthusiasm.
(laughing)
So North Dakota, is Fargo in North Dakota?
Am I correct?
- Yes.
- Okay cool, North Dakota nice.
It's snowy, it's cold.
What's their main export?
(mumbling)
Oil, what word did you say?
Someone says me over there oil cool.
(indistinct)
We're now starting a
debate about North Dakota,
I feel that it was two
very specific camps,
(laughing)
there's,
people who like Nikola Tesla,
people who like North Dakota.
And no meeting in the middle of there.
Okay, so the suggestions
for one final time,
Hanes Tighty Whities,
7-Eleven, North Dakota,
monkey torture and Nikola Tesla.
This then is, I'm gonna
stick all those together
to create a freestyle rap,
that is a rap made up on the spot.
Should we drop that beat?
(applause)
It is entirely improvised,
entirely made up.
Let's get a bit of volume in it as well.
And don't worry, it won't be anywhere near
as atrociously bad as
you're expecting it to be.
And you seem very unconvinced
by this, don't you?
Just arms crossed.
♪ Are you wearing like
a durag under your top ♪
♪ Yeah, pulling a bandana out ♪
♪ Okay that's fun ♪
♪ Picking on a guy, who don't deserve it ♪
♪ There we move on Nicola from Serbia ♪
♪ Where this guys had a bad
time dropping down war crimes ♪
♪ Let me talk about the
science in his mad mind ♪
♪ Making all the coils transmit electric ♪
♪ You can go to Griffith
Park, you can spot it ♪
♪ Got a Tesla coil it will
send it like an arc light ♪
♪ It's so amazing yet
you could spark life ♪
♪ Genius inventor like Einstein ♪
♪ Find his mind in the
past of his whole time ♪
♪ Very smart, really very clever ♪
♪ I'm sorry that I thought
you were Nikolai Mr. Tesla ♪
♪ Dropping that I but not the IQ ♪
♪ If you're hungry, I don't advise you ♪
♪ To go to a place opposite
of Gourmet Heaven ♪
♪ It's hell tastes bad
when you eat 7-Eleven ♪
♪ Getting all the hot dogs ♪
♪ Get in all the Cachitos
I try and buy them ♪
♪ And then I starts to
blow up my back passage ♪
♪ Yeah, always got the fear ♪
♪ It's clear you buy it there ♪
♪ You will get diarrhea,
but it's convenient ♪
♪ I want some more it makes sense ♪
♪ Nominatively convenient
store you can buy things ♪
♪ Like chewing gum and
Doritos and probably hold up ♪
♪ With a gun and take the money
and they'll give it to you ♪
♪ They are like, that's all right ♪
♪ What You gonna do? ♪
♪ I say flee before report has
come and then I go to the zoo ♪
♪ And torture all monkeys ♪
♪ And all the apes and the simians ♪
♪ I begin in the electrodes
I'm a silly man ♪
♪ I'm like a scientist
doing the experiments ♪
♪ These really kind of
hellish yeah not heaven sent ♪
♪ If I had a monkey right here ♪
♪ I'd put his fluffy ass
on this sweet chair ♪
♪ And take a little axe to his knee caps ♪
♪ Chopping off his left
shin it might relapse ♪
♪ It might kick back eyes
roll back in his face ♪
♪ So I'm like, this is for
The Planet Of The Apes ♪
♪ That's probably how it
started I don't know ♪
♪ Never seen the movie so
I can just go over there ♪
♪ Yeah, my mind's so flighty ♪
♪ Talk about my pantie yeah
tightie whities not really ♪
♪ Don't picture them in your mind ♪
♪ If I wore them, this is
probably how I'd mind ♪
♪ My testicles are so well gripped ♪
♪ They're made by Hanes ♪
♪ So my balls don't slip ♪
♪ The stay in them place,
just like they're frozen ♪
♪ A tight white grip
on the man's scrotum ♪
♪ It fits right there got
to keep the pubes in ♪
♪ So old, washed them not in a museum ♪
♪ Some people don't wash them every day ♪
♪ You could smell them
coming from a mile away ♪
♪ Lady over there saying,
oh, why would you say it ♪
♪ Apologies after the monkey display ♪
♪ It should come as no surprise
that I've got exposed thighs ♪
♪ Because it cuts up front ♪
♪ We called them Y-fronts ♪
♪ In my country ♪
♪ If a wore them now it's
in the front to see ♪
♪ I'm just filling time,
cause I forgot the last word ♪
♪ Shout it out remind me like
a cheeky little bird yeah ♪
♪ A coldplay so you know,
one never go there ♪
♪ I never take a flight
up to North Dakota ♪
♪ I might go cause I
liked the Coen brothers ♪
♪ Fargo South Dakota,
they know (mumbling) ♪
♪ They export oil and then
make a lot of wealth ♪
♪ But if you're there, it's
probably bad for your health ♪
♪ Cause the only place
to eat is at 7-Eleven ♪
♪ Or the food that tastes
bad because it's deep fried ♪
(cheering)